I don't really care about owning my
masters and I'm just like whatever I'm
gonna sing I'm so um dead it's fine
it'll be fine and then somebody I can
make money off Matt okay Kelly Clarkson
continues to be well the best but hers
is more like like I really calf oh
you're a little more than half my stuff
and hers is a hundred percent of its
that's her so I can see how it would
matter yep Kelly was on Sundays special
episode of The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon talking all about my favorite
Taylor Swift let's go back in July after
music manager Scooter Braun purchased a
big machine records a KA the label that
owns all of Taylor's master recordings
Taylor gots pretty upset at the time
Kelly Clarkson tweeted this encouraging
Taylor to re-record her master's quotes
just a thought you should go in and
rerecord all the songs that you don't
own the Masters on exactly how you did
them but put brand new art and some kind
of incentive so fans will no longer buy
the old versions I'd buy all the new
versions just to prove a point since all
that went down Taylor has revealed she
will be recording all her old masters
now could you rerecord oh yeah
might you do that oh yeah that's a plan
yeah absolutely
again Taylor's like the artists like
she's been riding since she was a little
girl right so it's like kind of her
diary so I get why she'd want to Kelly
also explained how she got the idea to
make that suggestion to Taylor Reba told
me she did that like oh really she told
me she did that she wanted to own her
masters and I was like well if it's that
important to you like find a way so and
she read cut all her music and did the
same musician same everything
that's where I got the idea yeah he also
talked to Kelly about Taylor pretty
recently she refused to take any credits
for inspiring Taylor you see the Taylor
Swift is now gonna rerecord her music
and it's because you suggested no it is
not what woman is the smartest business
woman I've ever seen in this industry
but she would have totally thought about
we actually ran into each other recently
and I was telling her I could get that
idea I got it from Reba No
on whether Taylor has plans to appear on
Kelly Clarkson's new talk show but I
think she should I also wouldn't be
opposed to a Kelly Taylor collab at some
point just sayin anyways that's it for
today for all the latest on Kelly Taylor
and your other favorite celebs keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Kraus
and PI for now